zusammengeschnitten und so die besten
szenen rausgeschnitten und da nehme ich
dann meine halbe stunde auf und stellt
dann aber nun zehnter aus also nur drei
minuten oder so was dann wo ihr das dann
angucken können sagt ihr euch so
herrlich aber jeder stelle gemacht
anstatt soja wir suchen jetzt die server
blog blog schreibt mir das einfach in
die kommentare schreibt mir ja oder nein
wenn ihr dort wollte ein komplett
abgeschrieben biko hätten in mailand
gewonnen hätten wir 60 euro aus einem
gemacht fick dich ac mailand hey leute
und herzlich willkommen zur allerletzten
folge vom mega trade das hier ist jetzt
quasi meine abschieds folge wo ich jetzt
noch mal so ein bisschen hier revue
passieren lassen
ein paar sachen ich sag mal abgebe ich
habe mir zwar noch überhaupt keine
gedanken gemacht an wen und wie viel an
was unklar weil er auch noch so und die
leute mit denen ich zu viel gemacht habe
die sind jetzt meistens auch schon
ausgetreten
ich weiß gar nicht ob ich überhaupt
irgendwas geben werde ich glaube ich
werde es einfach alles hier so für die
ewigkeit stehen lassen habe ich mir so
spontan überlegt weil ich weiss nicht
irgendwie wenn das jetzt die letzte
folge ist und ihr nachher die welt zum
download kriegt dann ist es ja irgendwie
bzw wenn alle fertig sind bekommt man ja
die welt zum download das haben wir euch
schon am anfang versprochen dann finde
ich irgendwie nicht so geil wenn was ich
wenn der ton ist man nicht anders dass
handys erst mal nicht so geil wenn ich
sage mal mehr oder weniger hier nichts
mehr drin steht bei mir in der wohnung
die kleine ich hoffe ihr versteht das
ein bisschen was ich meinem ein jetpack
hab ich gar nicht mehr
ich war jetzt schon eine woche oder zwei
wochen nicht mehr drauf ist es auf jeden
fall heftig da das haus hat sich ein
bisschen verändert bei sparkasse ich
bestimmt wieder etwas verändert und bei
vielen anderen leuten auch die die
gründe warum ich jetzt austrete ist halt
einfach
ja ich hab's euch ja mehr oder weniger
entscheiden apropos huemer der küste
können jemand vorbei und ich hab's euch
ja mehr oder weniger entscheiden lassen
weil ich hatte immer weniger bock drauf
und auch die tatsache dass ich einfach 2
wochen jetzt hier drauf und auch einfach
nicht geguckt habe so wie es gerade
läuft und so zeigt er ist sehr sehr
wenig bock drauf habe
deswegen wollte ich auch an diesem video
nochmal gleich am ende also schaut bitte
zum ende da spielt jetzt schon mal vor
bis zu den letzten in der letzten minute
wollte ich euch was fragen was ich ob
ihr was ihr davon haltet sage ich mal
ich laufe immer so ein bisschen her
während ich jetzt ein bisschen rede bzw
kommen die ganze richtung kann ich erst
mal an lassen 8man wir wollten noch so
viel also etwa wir wollten ja noch so
viel machen eigentlich näher wir wollten
ja noch eigentlich jeden die lampen vom
keller wollte ich mir oben und als dach
oder als boden machen
dann wollte ich allgemein jemanden
keller weiter bauen was ist ein bett
hier eigentlich
das habe ich mal glaube ich gemacht um
euch die demonstrative die boshafte
power meines diamond race zu
präsentieren
hier unten dieses riesen diese
riesenkrake wollten noch stopfen bei
simon explodiert wieder alles macht ihr
eigentlich noch weiter ich weiß es gar
nicht werden wir auch schon lange nichts
mehr von mir sicher dass für den auch
schon ende könnt ihr mehr schreiben wenn
ihr dabei wo ist eigentlich unnötig weil
ich bin draußen mir nichts angehen
es ist sehr schön hier so einige
schulplatz cool ich komme auch nicht
mehr raus
scheiße wieso kann ich dir so hoch
springen alter
es wird erkannt warum warum kann ich den
zwei blöcken springen erfreulicher zwei
blöcke hochspringen mich verarschen und
ging dass es hier also keine blöcke mich
heraus zu bauen
ich bleib beim thema die folge soll
eigentlich nicht allzu lang werden und
zwar hatte ich halt immer weniger bock
auf dieses projekt und ich finde für
mich ist es halt so dass alle die mich
schon sehr sehr lange abonniert haben
die wissen dass wenn ein projekt mir
nicht gefällt oder wenn ich da keinen
bock drauf habe dann werde ich das auch
da sage ich dann noch ganz klipp und
klar meine meinung weil ich weiß nicht
ich finde man sollte nur die sachen
machen die einfach wirklich spaß machen
und dann wird zum beispiel im megapark
keinen spaß mehr macht halt auf dem
motto es keinen spaß mehr machen dann
läuft dann höre ich halt auf mit mod
reviews also wenn ihr also versteht was
meine wie komme ich denn jetzt hier weg
ohne dass ich mich eventuell 1000 mäßig
doll versetzte da eventuell leder unten
auf jeden fall
wie komme ich da raus ohne mich heftig
zu verletzen da bleib ich fall wieder
rein und den tod geil
also wenn mir ein projekt nicht mehr so
viel spaß macht dann bin ich eine person
die dann auch sagt sohn eheleute wow
denke mir dann noch keine jahr hat halt
einen bogen dann hatte ich denke da dann
auch irgendwie kann der junge aus ich
dachte an einfacher leute
es liegt irgendwie daran das projekt mir
nicht mehr so viele geil mir nicht mehr
so viel spaß beim festakt nitrate
wiederum kann nix einsammeln
dass das projekt mehr halt auch so
allgemein nicht mehr so ganz mundet
deswegen wollte ich das ganze alte
ändert euch dann immer gefragt ja was
haltet ihr davon oder wollt ihr lieber
dass ich drin leider bleibe aber dafür
dann halt mehr oder weniger ganz ganz
selten nur ein paar videos hochladen was
sagt ihr dazu
die meisten waren exakt das war welchen
regionen da war von diesem circle blabla
von diesen dingen bieten blog lol da
sind vier alter übertreibt halt noch
mehr sachen so dass manche sprung
verstärkung wird cool recht cool
ich laufe noch ein bisschen weiter
umschauen und man den puffer auch re wie
manchester verlegt
ja deswegen halt mehr oder weniger habe
ich das ganze projekt beendet und ihr
wart ihr auch so drauf so ja auch wenn
du keinen spaß mehr an hast dann hör auf
weil ich denke ich als zuschauer wenn
ich mich schauen würde auf youtube ich
würde auch sagen hör auf bevor du hier
unser source and roll von ghom und mir
war das glaube ich ich würde die auch
eine person nicht mehr schauen wollen
die verluste auf ein projekt hat
deswegen naja bin ich dann auch so ein
bisschen weil sie nicht bin ich da
meiner meinung das hört sich voll
komisch an
naja jedenfalls dass die gründe warum
ich halt nicht mehr so richtig bock
drauf haben und hier ist auch wirklich
also es hat sich eine menge verändert
mit regeln und paar leute hier
reingekommen sind das hat einiges
verändert und bleib ich möchte jetzt
keine irgendwie an schwätzen ich habe
auch alle ganz verliebt die hier sind
das ist riesig aber ich weiß nicht jetzt
haben sich so ein paar sachen verändert
und ich finde dass das geld zu dem
projekt dazu also das ist jetzt nicht in
die böse gemeint das gehört natürlich
selbstverständlich zu dem projekt dazu
dass da eventuell sich auf dauer etwas
verändert und eventuell ist es hat mir
noch spaß gemacht bis zum ende hin nur
dann halt habe ich mir immer mehr
herausgefunden ja ich mache mir andere
sache nicht mehr spaß als megaprojekte
megaprojekt ist immer so ein zwang und
weshalb sonst was aufzunehmen habe ich
da half auch kein bock mehr drauf der
maler feininger
deswegen ist das jetzt so quasi letzte
volk ich laufe jetzt noch ein bisschen
rum damit ihr sohn wissen was da war mir
alles rum einfach damit ihr euch nochmal
einen kleinen einblick geben und danach
dann halt wirklich never er war wieder
was von megaprojekten warten bald alle
auf das neue projekt von simon wovon ich
immer noch nichts gehört habt bzw wenn
ich mich mit anderen oder halt irgendwie
komme wieder keine ahnung wem dann
wissen die auch nix ich weiß nicht wie
vielleicht schon geplant hat aber es hat
sich auf jeden fall cool an bisher was
ich so gehört habe und da könnt ihr euch
auf jeden fall heftig mächtig drauf
freuen weil das dann wieder bei mir sein
hauptprojekt werden wird was denn so
machen werde
was tust du hier noch so alleine belgien
einfach belgien belgien ist die antwort
auf alles deswegen noch mäßig hier so
toll ich hoffe euch hat das komplett dem
megaprojekt spaß gemacht mit mir ich war
am anfang sehr viel reich am ende auch
zwischendrin auch immer waren verletzt
bei mir dabei und ich bin halt auch sehr
darauf gestorben letztes hat einen
zusammenschnitt mehr gesendet aus allen
toten das ging dann schon so viele
minuten
aber wie ich fand es irgendwie das nicht
finde das geld dazu also das gehört zu
meiner unterhaltung und ein bisschen
dazu soviel bisschen witzig so ein
bisschen halt völlig idiotisch möchte
jetzt die sagen tollpatsch riecht ein
bisschen weil ich denke ihr wisst alle
dass ich nicht dumm bin und will schon
auf sky teams allein auf allein
ja ich hoffe halt einfach es hat spaß
gemacht schreibt mir doch mal eine
kommentare was ihr so bei mir so am
geilsten fand warst du die die
rettungsaktion so von simon und ironie
die dann so schief gegangen ist oder war
es also nicht der tod mit den ganz am
anfang
im links im chat aus managen schnauze
oder was der tote ganz am anfang mit
denen an der höhle oder war es mit
bronze die mich auf ihrem grundstück
gekillt haben oder was der epische
luftkampf mit denen oder was weiß ich
keine ahnung oder die folgen wo ich im
mega viel mit technik gemacht hat jeder
hat ja so seine eigenen sachen die er so
gerne mag gefeiert also schreibt mir das
mal die kommentare was ihr denkt so ja
so wichtig dass ich was ich so am
meisten gefallen hat und jetzt nochmals
zu der sache die ich gesagt habe ich
erwähnt habe wo ich mein fahrrad ihr was
ich solche fragen möchte nach da hinten
könnte noch ebene laufen und zwar die
meisten von euch kennen ja mehr oder
weniger ab juli bei das ist der meist
abonnierte youtuber und dem
attraktivsten klicks und keine ahnung
was noch alles
jedenfalls ist mir natürlich drauf ich
guck dir noch schon sehr sehr lange und
der macht halt täglich ein video sowie
ich voll von dem cloud nein ich kann
einfach nicht mehr hoch aber erwacht
teilt das ist auch cool das ist alles so
in diese kleinen so komisch irgendwie
alles so weise nicht so mäßig tätig
er macht halt so jeden tag ein video
aber dann halt so dings mäßig so
bearbeitet und dann halt weiß nicht zehn
minuten fünf minuten oder so und ich
werde nicht schaffen sondern bearbeitet
das video jeden tag hochzuladen dass ich
auf gar keinen fall schafft mit mit
schule und abi und training und das auf
kleinsten aber was sie davon halten
würde wenn ich mal so ab und zu
eventuell so was wie prob hand oder so
kennt ihr ja wahrscheinlich prob hand
ist ja dieses wo man sich versteckt also
halten sieg aber nicht in minecraft
sondern in bings in gary j counter
strike mäßig das dann irgendwie oder
auch manchmal so minecraft zwei begrenzt
oder so manchmal so wenn ich das dann
mache dann immer so links max payne so
zusammengeschnitten und so die besten
szenen rausgeschnitten und da nehme ich
dann die mineral bestimmt auf und
schneidet dann aber nun zehnter raus
also nur drei minuten oder so was dann
wo ihr das dann angucken können dann
sagt ihr euch so herrlich aber jeder
stelle gelacht anstatt soja wir liegen
jetzt server bla bla bla bla es geht um
den see kolosse ohne das alles also da
würd mich eure meinung auf jeden fall
interessieren
ich würde alle meine sachen in die kiste
dass wenn ihr schreibt mir das einfach
in die kommentare schreibt mir ja oder
nein wenn ihr das wollt day soll ich das
gar nicht mehr sortiert hier egal
ein komplett abgeschrieben bei tipico
hätten mailand gewonnen hätten wir 60
euro aus einem gemacht fick dich ac
mailand na ja gut dann würde ich sagen
freunde das war die letzte um eine
rüstung das war die letzte letzte folge
vom mega projekt jurist und kriegt ihr
nicht jedoch kommt die kritik war meine
letzte folge vom mega projekt ja wie
gesagt ich hoffe sagte spaß mal schreibt
mir die kommentare auf wir so eine serie
ob ihr das mal so wollt dass ich so ein
paar sachen so einfach so bearbeitete
und da habe ich auf jeden fall am ball
ist die mega epische mit dem blick auf
die monsters ist die tam ag los ob ihr
das haben wollt oder ob er sagt lieber
weniger und es wird er da nicht haupt
ersetzen seien aber halt dass ich das
mal so ab und zu dann mache schreibt mir
das einfach in die comments unten und
geht mal daumen hoch wenn ihr sagt hey
das mega was hammergeil es aber ich
freue mich auf das neue projekt gibt tom
rother wenn das mega truck bus und das
neue projekt auch scheiße sein
entscheidet euch und wir fest jetzt aber
den kuchen auf ihr zu ende und dann sage
ich tschüss